se llaman los acuerdos de abraham un
hombre que hace referencia al patriarca
que comparten el judaísmo el islam y el
cristianismo el acuerdo entre israel y
emiratos árabes unidos para normalizar
las relaciones negociado por eeuu ha
sido calificado de un avance histórico
por los líderes estadounidenses e
israelíes
acordaron finalizar un histórico acuerdo
de paz todos dijeron que esto sería
imposible en base a los logros que este
es el mayor avance hacia la paz en el
mundo árabe en los últimos 26 años
robadas por instrucción este hecho ha
dividido la opinión internacional
algunos la elogian por promover la paz y
otros la califican de campaña electoral
para donald trump y benjamin netanyahu
quienes han estado buscando una victoria
política exterior
muchos palestinos creen que el acuerdo
los margina ellos confían en los países
árabes para que los ayuden a resistir la
ocupación israelí así que ahora se
sienten traicionados israel de hecho
acordó suspender sus planes de anexión
de partes de cisjordania como parte del
acuerdo aunque netanyahu ha enfatizado
que estos planes se retrasan pero no se
cancelan además del intercambio de
embajadores y embajadas las relaciones
normales entre emiratos árabes unidos e
israel' también deberían significar
colaboración e inversión turismo
telecomunicaciones y una serie de otras
posibilidades un aspecto clave será la
seguridad en particular hacer frente a
la creciente presencia estratégica de
irán en la región y su programa nuclear
pero israel y emiratos árabes unidos ya
tienen vínculos de seguridad bien
establecidos por lo que esta parte del
acuerdo podría ser poco más que una
formalidad